I'm a historian.
Steve told us about the future
of little technology;
I'm going to show you some
of the past of big technology.
This was a project to build a 4,000-ton
nuclear bomb-propelled spaceship
and go to Saturn and Jupiter.
This took place in my childhood, 1957-65.
It was deeply classified.
I'm going to show you some stuff
that not only has not been declassified,
but has now been reclassified.
(Laughter)
If all goes well, next year I'll be back,
and I'll have a lot more to show you,
and if all doesn't go well,
I'll be in jail, like Wen Ho Lee.
(Laughter)
So, this ship was basically
the size of the Marriott Hotel,
a little taller and a little bigger.
And one of the people
who worked on it at the beginning
was my father, Freeman,
there in the middle.
That's me and my sister, Esther,
who's a frequent TEDster.
I didn't like nuclear
bomb-propelled spaceships.
I mean, I thought it was a great idea,
but I started building kayaks.
So we had a few kayaks.
Just so you know
that I am not Dr. Strangelove.
But all the time I was out there
doing these strange kayak voyages
in odd, beautiful parts of this planet,
I always thought in the back
of my mind about Project Orion,
and how my father and his friends
were going to build these big ships.
They were actually going to go --
Ted Taylor, who led the project,
was going to take his children.
My father was not going
to take his children,
that was one of the reasons we sort
of had a falling out for a few years.
(Laughter)
The project began in '57
at General Atomics there,
that's right on the coast at La Jolla.
Look at that central building
right in the middle of the picture.
That's the 130-foot diameter library.
That is exactly the size
of the base of the spaceship.
So put that library
at the bottom of that ship --
that's how big the thing was going to be.
It would take two or three thousand bombs.
The people who worked on it
were a lot of the Los Alamos people
who had done the hydrogen bomb work.
It was the first project funded by ARPA.
That's the contract where ARPA
gave the first million dollars
to get this thing started.
"Spaceship project officially begun.
Job waiting for you. Dyson."
That's July '58.
Two days later, the space traveler's
manifesto explaining why --
just like we heard yesterday --
why we need to go into space:
"... trips to satellites
of the outer planets.
August 20, 1958."
These are the statistics of what would be
the good places to go and stop.
Some of the sizes of the ships,
ranging all the way up
to ship mass of 8 million tons.
So that was the outer extreme.
Here was version two: 2,000 bombs.
These are five-kiloton yield bombs,
about the size of small Volkswagens;
it would take 800 to get into orbit.
Here we see a 10,000-ton ship
will deliver 1,300 tons
to Saturn and back --
essentially, a five-year trip.
Possible departure dates:
October 1960 to February 1967.
These are trajectories going to Mars.
All this was done by hand,
with slide rules.
The little Orion ship,
and what it would take
to do what Orion does with chemicals:
you have a ship the size
of the Empire State Building.
NASA had no interest;
they tried to kill the project.
The people who supported it
were the Air Force,
which meant that it was all secret.
And that's why when you get something
declassified, that's what it looks like.
Military weapon versions
that carried hydrogen bombs
that could destroy half the planet.
There's another version there that sends
retaliatory strikes at the Soviet Union.
This is the really secret stuff:
how to get directed energy explosions.
So you're sending the energy
of a nuclear explosion --
not like just a stick of dynamite,
but you're directing it at the ship.
And this is still a very active subject.
It's quite dangerous,
but I believe it's better to have
dangerous things in the open
than think you're going
to keep them secret.
This is what happened
at 600 microseconds.
The Air Force started
to build smaller models
and actually started doing this.
The guys in La Jolla said,
"We've got to get started now."
They built a high-explosive
propelled model.
These are stills from
film footage that was saved
by someone who was supposed
to destroy it but didn't,
and kept it in their basement
for the last 40 years.
So, these are three-pound charges of C4;
that's about 10 times
what the guy had in his shoes.
(Laughter)
This is Ed Day putting --
So each of these coffee cans
has three pounds of C4 in it.
They're building a system that ejects
these at quarter-second intervals.
That's my dad in the sport coat there,
holding the briefcase.
So, they had a lot of fun doing this.
But no children were allowed;
my dad could tell me he was building
a spaceship and going to go to Saturn,
but he could not say
anything more about it.
So all my life I have wanted
to find this stuff out,
and spent the last four years
tracking these old guys down.
These are stills from the video.
Jeff Bezos kindly, yesterday,
said he'll put this video up
on the Amazon site --
some little clip of it.
(Applause)
So, thanks to him.
They got quite serious
about the engineering of this.
The size of that mass, for us,
is really large technology in a way
we're never going to go back to.
If you saw the 1959 --
this is what it would feel
like in the passenger compartment;
that's acceleration profile.
(Laughter)
And pulse-system yield:
we're looking at 20-kiloton yield
for an effective thrust
of 10 million newtons.
Well, here we have a little problem,
the radiation doses at the crew station:
700 rads per shot.
(Laughter)
Fission yields during development:
they were hoping to get
clean bombs; they didn't.
Eyeburn: this is what happens
to the people in Miami who are looking up.
(Laughter)
Personnel compartment noise: that's
not too bad; it's very low frequencies,
it's basically like these sub-woofers.
And now we have ground-hazard assessments
when you have a blow-up on the pad.
Finally, at the very end in 1964,
NASA steps in and says,
"OK, we'll support a feasibility study
for a small version
that could be launched with Saturn Vs
in sections and pieced together."
So this is what NASA did,
getting an eight-man version
that would go to Mars.
They liked it because the guys could
kind of live there and be like,
"It's like living in a submarine."
This is crew compartment.
It switches, so what's
upside down is right side up
when you go to artificial gravity mode.
The scientists were still
going to go along;
they would take seven astronauts
and seven scientists.
This is a 20-man version
for going to Jupiter:
bunks, storm cellars, exercise room.
You know, it was going
to be a nice, long trip.
The Air Force version:
here we have a military version.
This is the kind of stuff
that's not been declassified,
just that people managed to sneak
home and after, you know,
on their deathbed,
basically, gave me that.
The sort of artist conceptions.
These are basically
PowerPoint presentations
given to the Air Force 40 years ago.
Look at the little guys there
outside the vehicle.
And one part of NASA was interested in it,
but the headquarters in NASA,
they killed the project.
So finally, at the end,
we can see the thing followed
its sort of design path right up to 1965,
and then all those paths came to a halt.
Results: none.
This project is hereby terminated.
So that's the end.
All I can say in closing is:
we heard yesterday that one of the 10
bad things that could happen to us
is an asteroid with our name on it.
And one of the bad things
that could happen to NASA
is if that asteroid shows up
with our name on it nine months out,
and everybody says,
"Well, what are we going to do?"
And Orion is really one
of the only, if not the only,
off-the-shelf technologies
that could do something.
(Laughter)
So I'm going to tell you
the good news and the bad news.
The good news is that NASA has a small,
secret contingency-plan division
that is looking at this, trying
to keep knowledge of Orion preserved
in the event of such a misfortune.
Maybe keep a few little
bombs of plutonium on the side.
That's the good news.
The bad news is, when I got
in contact with these people
to try and get some documents
from them, they went crazy
because I had all this stuff
that they don't have,
and NASA purchased 1,759 pages
of this stuff from me.
So that's the state we're at;
it's not very good.
(Laughter)
(Applause)